c'est donc après une procédure
judiciaire riche de rebondissements que
laurent fabius ancien premier ministre
georgina dufoix ancien secrétaire d'état
aux affaires sociales et edmond hervé
ancien secrétaire d'état à la santé
seront jugés devant la cour de justice
la mise en cause de ses trois ministres
socialistes démarre à l'automne 92
une affaire qui prendra immédiatement un
tour politique françoise valais et
thierry kurt et les faits remontent à
mai 83 où l'on apprend que le virus du
sida est transmissible par le sang
si certains pays prennent des
dispositions la france tarde à réagir
les collectes dans les prisons lieu à
haut risque continue jusqu'en 86 ans 84
on sait que chauffer les produits
inactive les virus cette technique n'est
pas utilisé en france avril 85 un test
de dépistage des donneurs existe
la france attendra ou de 85 pour le
rendre obligatoire
résultat les produits contaminés
circulent
premières victimes les hémophiles et les
transfusés en 88 arrivent les premières
plaintes contre le centre national de
transfusion sanguine seul fournisseur
des produits en 92
michel garretta directeur du cnts et
condamné à quatre ans de prison
les familles des victimes sont révoltés
c'est un appel à quatre ans seulement
garetta ces mêmes familles dénoncent
l'absence de hauts responsables dans le
box des accusés et se retourne contre
les ministres laurent fabius premier
ministre de l'époque
edmond hervé secrétaire d'état à la
santé et georgina dufoix ministre des
affaires sociales
en 94 ces trois ministres sont
poursuivis pour complicité
d'empoisonnement un crime passible de la
réclusion à perpétuité
parallèlement se poursuit une
instruction visant les médecins et les
membres des cabinets ministériels
à ce jour trente et une personnes ont
été mis